Sophie get off it stop it can we be
naive are we I'm worried now we are we
are being naive
um so look you know Tick Tock gave
evidence to my committee where they said
that there was no way that individuals
working in China could get access to the
data of Britain's but what we've now
seen is that people working in China for
tick tock hacked into European data so
they could track down the source of a
journalist because what Tick Tock does
is it gives away the data that makes you
most vulnerable who are you friends with
what are your interests what are the
interests you have that you may not want
publicly disclosed who having private
conversations with the locations you go
to there's a reason why China has this
app there's a reason why they're buying
up gay dating apps our data is a key
vulnerability and China is building a
tech totalitarian state on the back of
our data so we have to get far more
serious about protecting ourselves